>> I'm with IDEO, one of the largest design companies in the,
in the world. I'm with Tim Brown, the CEO of IDEO, and,
Tim has written this very interesting book, Change By Design, which includes
among other things, a big section on the importance of design thinking.
So Tim, design thinking. One of the points you argue, is that it doesn't just
make you a better designer, it makes you better at anything. Tell us about that.
>> I've always thought as, the one of
the wonderful things about being a, being a designer
is not just that I get to lots, work on lots of exciting projects, but it helps
me in my life, right? So I, and
when I want something as simple I'm going to throw
a dinner party for some friends so I
start. Instead of just turning up at, you know,
7 o'clock and thinking about what I'm going to make. I actually design
that, I try and design that experience. I think well who am I
going to bring together and what's the space going to be like and how does
the food and the space work together. All of these things that I
naturally think about as a designer. And I think that's what design thinking
does for you. It's a set of tools that allows you to approach
life, particularly the parts of life where it might be advantageous to solve
the problem differently, that allows you to approach that with some level of
confidence because you got some ways of going about it.
And we have many, we're taught at school many ways
of analyzing problems, of put, picking them apart and studying
little pieces of them. Often that's very valuable. But, but design
thinking gives you a different way of tackling a problem.
Often, often ones that are centered around the needs of the
people you're trying to solve for. That might be yourself.
It might be a customer in in if, if, if you're
in a professional environment, it might be you're
colleagues. Int in in a work, work environment. It's
centered around that. And so it starts with thinking
hard, looking hard, listening hard and trying to study
people. And understand, in this instance, wh, what
their issues might be, what their problems might be.
w, how they're thinking, how they, how they are,
how they are navigating the world or dealing with
the world at, at, at, at hand. And then
using that as the starting point for having ideas.
>> Mm hm, I actually, I often describe it,
don't solve the problem. In fact, as a consultant never solve
the problem you're given, but figure out what the real problem is.
>> Yeah, figure out what the question is. I mean, many of us think we're
talk about, when people talk about creativity
or design, I think it's all about solving
the problem and, and being creative about
that. But I find generally the most interesting
solutions come out of the most interesting
questions and, and so that insight about what
the problem might really be, is often the most important than the
biggest creative step. And so, if you just assume you know the
question then especially if it's the same question that everybody else is,
is asking. Then you'll probably get to the same answer that everybody it
getting to. But if you study a little bit and think a
little bit, and maybe look at it, look at the, look at things
from a slightly different perspective, really get under the skin of the
people that you are trying to serve, it's surprising how often you end
up completely re-framing the question.
>> And so, as you point out, this could be
used by anybody, a business person, an artist, a journalist, anybody.
>> Yeah. I mean, you, you can think about how you use it. I mean, one
of the things I talk about in, in, in, in, in my book is, is ways
of applying design thinking to your own life.
I mean, think about your career. How can
I apply a design thinking approach to my
career, to the choices I make, or, or, or,
absolutely how you apply it in your, in, in your,
in your workplace. No matter what you do. You might, you
might work in the finance department, have a company, and be
thinking, well how could I be, find more creative solutions to
the way that we, the processes that work within our organization. Or the way
that we come together as, as, as, as people. And so I think whatever your
background, if you have the, the tools to hand, the thinking tools to hand,
and the confidence to use them. that, that, that design can be a great help.
>> Thank you.